[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday March 5th
and I'm coming to you from the yetis
childhood bedroom I'm sure you've been
thrilled to see the free Hank movement
that's been going on in the comments
there have been posters and there have
even been t-shirts Hank it just goes to
show what a vocal minority can do they
can make it seem like you didn't do
anything wrong at all like we're crazy
to think that it was textual
communication when you said see you
tomorrow in text while communicating
with me they'll just be like free Hank
because we said so and then the rest of
us will be all like well we didn't make
t-shirts saying punish Hank so maybe we
should free Hank no we shouldn't free
Hank you committed a punishable offense
and ye shall be punished
however the vocal minority that is the
free Hank movement has gotten me to
thinking that maybe my punishment for
you shouldn't be so mean as your
punishments for me have been so Hank
here's your punishment there's the part
that you like peeps and the part that
you'll hate spending money first you
will purchase 100 full-sized
peeps they can be pink they can be
yellow they can be green whatever color
you want but they must be full-sized and
there must be 100 of them according to
the internet that's going to cost you
approximately $19 which I realize will
be significantly more painful than
waxing your chin but I'm just getting
started then in a 6 minute period you
will eat as many peeps as you can now
Hank remember I don't want anyone to die
during Brotherhood 2.0 it's easy to
aspirate on peeps please take your time
make sure you chew once the 6 minute
period has ended you will count the
peeps you have not eaten you will then
distribute those peeps to worthy
recipients in the city of Missoula now
here's the catch however many peeps you
don't eat in that 6 minute period you
will contribute that many dollars to a
new bank account that I've set up the
bank account will be known as the
Brotherhood 2.0 fund for decreasing suck
levels worldwide formerly known as the
Brotherhood 2.0 Melissa and Amy concert
fund Hank we will use your contribution
to this
fund and future contributions from us
and possibly our viewers in order to
increase the overall level of worldwide
awesomeness for instance maybe we'll
send melissa to a concert and then after
that maybe will help cure malaria Hank
you can look at this as a punishment but
you can also look at it as a project
we're starting something here something
important something that's going to
allow us to decrease the overall level
of the world suck how much are we going
to decrease suck levels that depends on
how many peeps you eat I'll see you
tomorrow